so recently I made some simple changes
to my daily routine which allowed me to
double my productivity and I was able to
do this by implementing five simple
proven tricks for getting more done part
one our first trick is all about finding
an exclusive location for your work and
ideally you want to select a location
where you haven't made any other
pre-existing connections I was able to
implement this trick by moving my work
location to a local cafe the second
trick I used to double my productivity
don't give yourself time to think
procrastination is an emotional problem
right the more you think about how much
you have to do the worse you start to
feel which means that you're less likely
to actually go and do it and you can
prevent this from happening by taking
quick action all I think about when I
wake up is okay I need to get dressed
and visit the cafe that's it and by
doing this I can trick myself to take
quick action so that I'll go to my
exclusive location so that my habit of
working there can kick in follow us for
more helpful tips